hey everybody how's it going her name is
mayuko and this is another minecraft
tutorial
hey everybody how's it going my name is
mayuko and welcome back to my channel so
today i have such a special guest on my
channel this is my husband scott
a lot of y'all thought that he was
actually like my uber driver in the day
in the life video but in fact no he's my
husband so i went on my instagram and
asked you all to ask us questions about
our relationship so because this is the
first time that i'm like really formally
introducing you on the channel i thought
we just answered a lot of the questions
that you asked us about who we are how
we met if we're gonna have kids in the
future what our career balance is like
all of that kind of stuff there'll be
time stamps in the description box down
below so if you want to skip to any of
them you can check them out down below
do you want to do like a quick
introduction about who you are
and what you're about no
mysterious man answers random questions
about my relationship with my husband so
let's dive into the very first question
how did you two meet
well i think came up to me one day
we met in college yeah so number one we
met in college we both went to ucsd
scots you're two years older than me and
i joined the same like engineering club
that he was in and so the day that i
joined i met him and like literally the
whole rest of the club so i was in my
second year of college i think you were
in your last year yeah and then i don't
think we really like
talked or hung out until much later yeah
we i mean we were friends for like a
whole year before we started dating we
would eat dinner and hang out with like
the whole group of people yeah the group
of people but we didn't really do like a
lot of one-on-one until the year later
next what attracted you to each other
what attracted you to me scott
i'd like to say
her
charm and
wit but that's just not true
because
the truth is
i am a shining bright star
that brought nothing but joy so much joy
so much joy i don't know i don't know
what it is
i mean i knew i thought you were really
cute i was just like okay he's he's like
my type and he's really cute and
i i mean that was like my first
impression of you and then after that i
feel like i just thought you were really
funny i remember that because i i really
like people who can make me laugh and i
thought you were hilarious and then also
i knew you were smart because you were a
much better student than me in college
tell me more tell me what what else is
great about me
that's it that's all that's good about
scott okay your turn what made me
attractive to you
a lot of the silliness i mean you made
me laugh but
not innocent not in the same way
i was laughing with you but you were
laughing at me
there's a lot of phrases mayuko used to
get wrong
she still does instead of
vicious cycle oh she would say
rigorous cycle
just little things like that okay how
did you guys decide to get married so we
were together for six years before we
got married and i think you proposed to
me at
five years or something like that no
four years four or five years something
like that how did we decide to get
married though
i mean i feel like ever since we started
dating i feel like you were kind of like
i'm in this for the long haul
in japanese there's a phrase called like
which means like
date with the
presumption that you want to get married
to each other yeah i went up to my
ukulele i was like i would like to date
you with the intention of
marriage
and so that that that's how it started
no that's not actually no i remember we
had our very first fight
when i every other like relationship i
had we was like we had one fight and it
was over because you know it was like a
lot of like
young high school relationship kind of
stuff like i wasn't emotionally mature
or like figured out how to deal with
conflict
[Laughter]
but i remember we had our first fight
and then i was like does this mean we're
gonna break up now and you were like
no
oh yeah i just remember being like what
are you talking what is wrong with you
and then i was just like oh she really
loves me i think like a lot of these
lessons and stuff of becoming like
emotionally mature was through our
relationship and so i think like for me
i was like yeah i want to get married to
him pretty early on there was a point
where i was like oh i can actually marry
this girl it was like when
i realized i guess when you could
grow
with me
or like just grow periods
as a human scott was like this is a very
good investment because she's gonna keep
growing
i think when dating somebody for a long
term they also start becoming like your
best friend and i think like seeing that
you had made sacrifices to like be with
me and you're really committed with me
in this relationship and you like
supported me through
like my work and like letting me do what
i wanted to do but still being like a
really
supportive partner and all of that but
we've kind of allowed each other to like
live the life that we want but together
which sometimes i'm kind of like in
dating with like personal relationships
it's unfortunate when two people are
good for each other but they want
different things and i think we got
really lucky in that we are good for
each other and we wanted like
things that wouldn't
make us be a part i guess yeah like we
could support each other through all of
that yeah so to answer the question i
don't think there was like a specific
moment or like you know
realization but it was like a lot of
little things that came together yeah
how do you maintain a healthy
relationship for so many years i think
we kind of talked about this like yeah
the communication i think communication
learning how to communicate is one thing
like i think a lot of people say like oh
just
you know communicate but like everybody
communicates differently and you change
too right so it's like
how i want to be talked to or with is is
different now than it was when we were
early 20s yeah i think that's the thing
too because it's not like you get good
at communication and you're like check
all done never have to like learn it
again but like the thing that helped us
especially because we've been through so
many life changes of like leaving
college getting first jobs moving
figuring out what we really want kind of
stuff we always have to be adjusting our
communication style because what we need
in those moments are different from
previous times so i think we calibrate
like really often yeah we also both do
our own individual work to figure out
like what we want we're not just like
lashing at each other and we can have
like well-formed conversations as much
as possible and just like a lot of it i
think is communicating expectations yeah
that's also true not just expectations
but like
how like yeah what you need to know how
they can support you yeah like being
more explicit about what we need from
each other are you uncle needs like set
rules like she needs a check she needs
like a
long if else or like a switch statement
that tells her like if this case and
then do this in this case then branch
out to here and then you know maybe
sometimes you see a fourth three okay
that's my yuko style
i'm very logical when it comes to all of
that i do think though that because
we're both software engineers we do like
tend to communicate very logically
together which helps with our
communication a lot yeah
but i think also we've gotten better at
like you know emotions are also
illogical and life is illogical but how
can we make sense of what's going on
together and we have like shared common
language with all of that too yeah
because i think we
approach problems differently
or like we feel differently about
problems or certain things but at the
end of the day we do have that shared
language to like communicate do you have
awkward periods of silence during
conversation slash being around each
other
yeah sometimes i mean like nothing i
mean it's not really awkward though no
it's not it's usually just like
well i'm just being quiet right now it's
not like i'm thinking of like
what are we gonna what are we gonna say
yeah i think that's like a very like
early dating symptom of like oh i'm
worried about what they're gonna think
so i'm gonna just like keep talking and
stuff and i don't want awkward sciences
because it's awkward but these times
sometimes silence is nice sometimes
silence is nice you know when we were
like early dating i i realized that this
was like a for real thing when we
started having more awkward silences
that were more comfortable i'll probably
talk to you about it too where i'm just
like is it okay that we're quiet right
now because
i got it i feel like you're judging me
or like i don't know if i'm doing
something wrong and what you probably
said was like me go chill out
what i probably said was like
huh what are you talking about
yeah awkward sciences are natural we sit
together a lot yeah we do so yeah we do
just sit
i mean like even when we were like early
dating i would just be like can i just
like be here but like not talk because i
think you would be like studying or
playing games or something i'm just like
i just want to be near you
that was yesterday i i still do that
so in the middle of this video we wanted
to take a moment to thank the sponsor of
this video bellroy so we both have
bellroy goods we have talked about
bellroy in previous videos i have the
bellroy sling mini and you have
the hide and seek wallet these were
gifted to us by bellroy and we've been
using them for months now yeah we really
like them do you want to talk about your
wallet it's a great wallet you know it's
even got the hide and seek part you can
you have like the money pouch
right and then you have a hidden money
pouch inside i don't know if you guys
can see that
there's like a little thing in the
middle
and then my sling mini literally was
like my daily driver in the front i put
like my wallet and my keys because it's
pretty slim in here and then in the back
i put things like a mask hand sanitizer
like chapstick eye drops
sometimes the vlog camera it can't
expand more and but i usually have it
this way my favorite feature of this is
that it unclips right here using magnet
so it's very easy sobaro is a certified
b corp that started in australia in 2010
they used to really start with like the
wallets and so that's probably what you
know them for but they make a lot more
products now so if you're interested in
checking out bellroy products and maybe
you want to pick up a sling mini
yourself or a hide-and-seek wallet then
make sure to check the link in the
description box down below for ten
percent off your purchase thank you so
much shavar for sponsoring today's video
and supplying us with your carries next
your favorite and least favorite thing
about my yuko um i think my favorite
thing is definitely your your drive your
passion it also helps me be motivated in
in my daily
routine or in like my life the least
favorite thing
would probably be
it's not like she's she's like
piling things up everywhere but
usually it leaves things slightly
messier than she found them yeah not
like completely like
yeah i think that might be that might be
the worst part it's not like
it's like she she half tried
and then halfway through she was just
like a screw it the best example would
be like when she's washing dishes like
half the time i find a dish with just
like a splash of food still on it in the
cupboard so i'm like how did this happen
next how does scott support you when it
comes to your anxiety
that's a good question i think it is
really hard to support somebody who's
going through it mentally whether they
have anxiety or depression or something
else because that person doesn't know
what's going on in your brain and so
part of it is like you kind of have to
do the work to like explain as best as
you can and if you can't then the best
thing that you can do is to like think
about what you really need and tell them
that directly so saying things like is
it okay if you like go out and eat today
instead of cook or like i want to go to
sleep early tonight is that okay or like
can you just like sit with me and hold
my hand for like five minutes or like
like i need space and just like let me
wallow yeah yeah if i just need to like
feel bad
and like i know that makes you worry but
then i'll just be like i'll be okay i
just need to do this and so like if you
just like let me be and i'll just really
just just let me sit for like five
minutes and i'll be better and of course
letting him know later i'll be like yes
i feel better now so that he knows that
i'm not just
feeling bad yeah sometimes she forgets
that part
which is really concerning yeah yeah but
eventually i figure it out when you guys
are mad at each other do you prefer to
not talk for a bit or hash it out
i think that depends on
the
situation we can both
be in a
bad
spot or like bad mental place to
not really
be able to communicate with each other
and so in those cases like leave each
other alone for a little bit
and then come back and talk about it
like for a long time we were able to
hash things out usually by the end of
the day
yeah usually i mean most problems we are
able to do that i think it's only
happened like once or twice where it
boils over like
which is fine like i think it helps to
sleep on it sometimes or helps to just
like let your emotions come yeah yeah
because i think when we have talked
while being very emotionally charged we
end up just like laughing at each other
and then we dig ourselves into a deeper
hole because not only have do we have to
fix the original problem but now we've
added to the problem
and so i think like yeah we definitely
like let each other cool down and if it
does take a night to do so then it will
yeah and then and then if it's like
one-sided where one person is upset
about something another person is just
completely like
then it's usually like that person
is the one kind of figuring out how to
navigate it like calm the situation down
or figure out when the right time to
talk is i think it's because of the way
that we like resolve problems is like
software engineer style
we have an agile board at the end of the
day like when we do fight and we are
trying to resolve it we're trying to
figure out like what was the problem to
begin with and what can we do to like
help each other too and i think it helps
that we both want to not fight
you guys both have demanding schedules
how do you manage to find the time for
each other
we live together
[Laughter]
when
you were commuting it was a little
harder
but i mean we always kind of
set aside like dinner time we eat dinner
together and we walk the dogs together
the dogs together because we're at least
like talking to each other about our day
or what's on our mind for at least 15-20
minutes dog walks dinner and then like
the
30 to 30 minutes to an hour before bed
yeah
where's next gen little mayuko and scott
who knows who knows where they are we
would like to have a family yeah
eventually eventually next your partner
took a leap towards a non-traditional
career that would make many
traditionalists nervous what was your
thought and emotional process throughout
the transition and even at present
especially during those periods when
she'd have her mental or creative blocks
i'm pretty
non-traditional i mean scott is the
biggest hipster
i don't think of careers only being like
be a software engineer you'd be a doctor
you have to be a lawyer to be successful
in life i think we're also pretty risk
tolerant or rebuild that into our lives
yeah because i think we're both kind of
like we both want to live our life to
the
best that we can
and so we're going to build in
quite a bit of flexibility to be able to
do non-traditional things
what about the emotional process like
weren't you worried about me
i knew
where all of your roadblocks would be i
guess right like we've talked about that
where it's like given how you were
working like your working pattern like
this would be unsustainable this would
probably fizzle out um you're not having
fun doing this but you just keep doing
this i don't know why what's wrong with
you
i i'm usually there as like
creative director almost yeah for the
most part i'm like pretty involved
already even though i'm i don't really
show up in videos or anything like that
so it's not like i had to do any extra
mental or emotional work when you
transitioned it it was kind of just more
of the same speaking of creative
endeavors and stuff scott is gonna start
doing these cooking streams on his
twitch channel uh and then we're also
gonna clip those into video youtube
content so we're probably gonna start a
family channel at some point yeah yeah
so
first live stream is gonna happen during
winter break sometime next week and so
we'll leave details to the stream where
you can find it all in the description
box down below so come hang out support
my hobby and it's new creative in denver
uh and i will definitely be there as
well next is scott japanese ii is scott
chinese what are you skype i am
taiwanese
yes okay the next question is in
japanese
basically the question is
the question basically asks what do you
think about international marriages and
from a japanese perspective basically
what how do you feel about marrying a
non-japanese person this person really
loves their american boyfriend but
they're very worried is the thing so i'm
gonna respond in japanese with some
subtext english subtitles at the end at
the bottom so y'all can follow along
it'll be like i'm writing them
[Laughter]
well
because
[Music]
well i wrote in japanese
thank you all so much for watching
today's video i hope you liked it thank
you all so much for your questions so
make sure to follow me on instagram if
you haven't done so already i'm almost
at 500k subscribers scott so tell them
to subscribe
subscribe make sure to give this video a
thumbs up if you'd like to see more
scott in my videos i'll leave links to
his twitch stream as well as the social
media things down below if you just want
to stalk him i guess because i know
that's what you're going to do
and we'll see you next time it's a lot
of fun
bye
[Music]
we did it we did that we did it
nope